everyone my name is Walter phonetic and
I am the host of channel awesome new
show awesome comics debuting on channel
awesome calm Monday March 28th thank you
guys where's my coffee cream sugar of
six shots of bourbon yeah every week
we'll be covering comic book related
news including talking about new TV
shows and movies hey new guy
do you have my cereal frosted
mini-wheats
in addition to that we'll be traveling
all around to different comic book
conventions shops and more to interview
you the fans hey you got my magazine
Shawn Mendes it's the future of America
so sit back flip through your favorite
comic book and join the discussion you
never know who's gonna pop up on the
show so make sure you're tuned in and
find out until then I'll see you on the
next page you know this whole new guy
thing isn't exactly the most glamorous
gig in the world but hey they told me I
could host my own show if I do what they
say
thank God Doug isn't here today though
oh my god the guy has me washed his
holes underwear who wears
twenty-five-year-old II walk adventure
briefs pretty sick if you ask me if he
knew that I had was telling you guys
that you'd probably kill me
and you can see my head yeah I was a
deal